nurse 30 to 1. you hit it you called it
on the show
i'm happy my bank account's happening
i'm giving away hoodies all show you're
getting a hoodie for that you get a
hoodie
all three of you get hoodies mikey how
many hoodies you giving out today like
45
i'm not counting who knows it's time
we're all going in together
we have somebody here who likes to face
the group chat you guys are the
absolute worst put some bleeping respect
on my name
why are you even in this group chat
you're not even betting and now you're
gonna tell me i'm wrong
you have no original takes get him out
again i don't want you in here get out
of the group chat
goodbye
[Music]
you just joined the br bed and group
chat
we've got locks we've got hoodies we got
takes on alex caruso
and we have to settle up a bet with
mikey locks
because he had a disastrous clippers bet
i am burned alongside kelly and vegas
greg ivory mikey locks and cabbie
richards
as always we're giving away hoodies all
show
keep firing off your takes in the
comments and before we talk about this
week's games
we have to talk about last week for
those of you who weren't here
this is what happened great intro
i am putting everything i have tonight
on the clippers everything you have
second mortgage
inheritance sign the prenup we're going
all in on the slippers there's no
way you can sign up you're already
married i don't really know how that
works
no i'm telling you there's no way
there's zero way the clippers lose
zero zero away zero away there was
i mean like honestly nobody would have
remembered that that i said what and i
already lost it all
i didn't see that happening either mike
just like i remember that happened don't
owe me a tattoo
from the bedding the internet is forever
locks
you are so dumb it it would have been
done dude burn like that stupid smirk
off your face okay it was a bad call i
made a bad
investment i lost all the money i lost
my mortgage it's fine
it wouldn't be dumb if that's all you
did it would have just been done
but you did this too you gave a bad sale
on a pick
it locks yeah if the clippers lose will
you shave your locks
if the clippers do where you shave your
head because i'm happy to fly
to san francisco to do it for you i'll
cut the man bun that i've been working
so
hard on off on the show live next week
if the clippers lose on the money line
you promised
more than that you got to go you got to
go down to the wall i'll go
go no mustache too i mean i'm fine with
that but like we just know mikey doesn't
pay his bet
this is what we're doing this is really
what we're going to do
i'm good for it
so you good for this what we're gonna do
wow this is what we're gonna do yes i'm
happy to do it i already lost
all vern i don't appreciate that smile
on your face right now you're waiting
what do you think i'm gonna do
asha check that his butt has to write
that's what wrote you were being
why paul george you're being outed
also wasn't trying i wasn't trying to
sell anybody a pick i made the pick
and i bet all my money and now i have to
do this bs yo you're not backing out of
this lox let's go there it is
there it is here it is it does this
really don't want to do i have to
get him amazing let's go here kelly
kelly you know it's a good man oh come
on there's another inch on there
so cut it off drop your take in the
comments
about how much dude that crash scissors
are those
oh yes should mikey shave off his old
mustache
or just half of it mikey can you cut oh
my god
it has to be half oh yeah let's see it
let's see it homie
sprinkle that yes
sprinkle that right here you have a bald
spot in the back
hold it make it rain
oh it's not even battered oh right off
yeah
you got to go all the way down to the
wood locks i'll be i'll be real with you
that was not as painful as the clippers
actually losing and all my teasers
getting blown so i have to do the stash
now too is that what it
wants to see this this isn't even a good
tv greg what are the people saying in
the comments
full sash or half stash
who said half's tap my guy josh my guy
my guy 90 eric says throw some salt on
the wound
yeah i agree with him let's throw some
salt on the wound and i'm getting i'm
seeing a lot of hats
i'm do i'm only doing half for now
because i want to keep the
the vibes going we need to be vibing we
need to spread good juju so i'll do half
and i'll hopefully win a bet off of it
you're gonna look better than mike fires
did when he had half of his
this
that's it stop right there yes this is
funny to you
[Laughter]
come closer to the camera you look so
stupid
closer you click don't lead up now i
need to walk
i need to walk i need to walk the only
way we get it back
you look like an idiot
all right all right let's talk nba
playoffs well mikey looks like this i
don't know about you guys
but we're all about alex caruso on vr
betting this week
we asked you on social how many points
he's gonna score today
in game three we got a ton of responses
we are gonna give away a hoodie on
social after the game so let's take a
look
fanduel has this line on crucial's game
three total
at five and a half points they are also
offering a
first quarter point prop with the line
set at one and a half points
so what do you guys stop i swear to god
you guys okay first of all you're not
laughing you look like you have a
caterpillar
really are you going to go through the
whole crusoe intro without not saying
that we're doing the crusoe bed
because you look like alex crusoe and i
could probably glue some of this to the
top of your head and maybe you don't
look like alex cruz
oh my god that's terrible don't say that
that is good
oh we can't make fun of her fox was
supposed to shave his whole head
to look like alex caruso yeah mikey
you got off too easy you all you have to
do is go find an open hair salon
somewhere in california to just like
scissor you up here because like that
was nothing that was like a little
that was like the size of coco's tail
burn looks like alex crusoe and i'm
still vibing because you are my blood
brother vern i'm not going to forget
that what you just made me do
being a bozo i'm taking it over we just
need one bucket
yeah you look like a bozo you did this
to yourself i look like a bozo
look at yourself yeah you
you are you looking forward to destroyed
all the mirrors in his condo
caruso yeah i'm selling my house because
the clippers lost
okay so listen we all love we all love
alex caruso and the caruso
he's a bench guy he'll come into he'll
he's like frank vogel's first or second
guy off the bench
so he'll come in like towards the end
like
three four minutes left in the first
quarter and the only way he's gonna
score is in transition either from a
rondo outlet pass
or lebron james outlet pass and the odds
of that happening are abby
is he going to get a bucket or is he not
going to get a bucket we're not going to
transition yes or no not not in the
first quarter there's no analysis
it's just one bucket or it's not a
bucket is very going to score or not
why is there not analysis mikey yeah you
and i
no you and i have to actually like think
these things through and process it
it might say yes yes or no can you move
your hand away from your face so we can
see how dumb you look
i'm sorry
okay so much pain right now i want you
guys to know that i am hurting from
laughing entirely too much
crusoe will score in the first quarter i
am with my key locks
he'll get about four minutes and get a
bucket maybe two free throws
don't care mikey i'm with you i'm with
you
and thank you oh my bald brother it's
fine we're together all
of us boys we're boys again
never weren't mikey greg what do you got
vern i got you i'm i'm just i'm in the
comments man and they
they are saying some funny things and
and caruso
they're giving me the vibes that caruso
will have over six points in the game
so if he's gonna have over six points
i'd definitely see him coming out
in the first quarter getting an easy
fast break bucket
from braun lay up dunk um i'm rocking
with a yes here i see caruso
hey no no no no no relax there mikey
no relax their might step back relax or
relax
there i cannot wait
for alex caruso to come in with 42
seconds left in the first quarter
one from one from the free throw line
and everything gets burnt
out that is exactly what's going to
happen
thank you for being the voice of reason
in this group chat i'm with you
alex caruso is not going to score one
and a half points in the first quarter
give me 100 on caruso right now bet for
me i know i already paid you back but
bet for me i need this i'm not doing a
lot did he
he paid me back in cryptocurrency we'll
we'll talk about it later
greg craig are the birds
saying we got to give some hoodies away
i want to give some hoodies away
tell me how to i am in the comments and
the
you are making fun of mikey my guy
r u hug one says mikey looks like a poor
man's garner menchu
oh my god
yo yo min's shoe is balling i'm taking
that burns
cryptocurrency left i've also been
seeing your shirt get a lot of uh
a lot of love people are loving your
shirt next one the next person that
comments on burn shirts i'm giving them
a hoodie i'm
just going to give them a hoodie uh jake
the snake we're going to give you a
hoodie for kelly being a team player
because kelly's always a team player so
when is kelly ever a team player kelly
is literally the least team player i've
ever met in my life she does
what i swear on the show i'm up to here
you cannot
no he just he just says the lip the lip
reading for those lip reading at home we
apologize for mikey
he looks so ridiculous he just team
player
team player that's me are you gonna keep
your uh
your little man bun as a memento for
this time
i'm giving it to you so you can glue it
to the top of your head
all right it is time for ask the chat we
have a squad member that needs our help
our friend at no limit b8 24
is sitting on a lakers championship
future ticket right now
he bet the lakers on fanduel and they
were plus 4-10
and he put 250 on them to win the title
look at that it pays out a grand
he currently has a cash out offer for
910 dollars
no limit you need all right i'm just
gonna cut you guys off right now
no no i'm just gonna cut everybody off
do not listen to anybody else
when they tell you to cash out you have
four two one on the team that is going
to win it all
the nuggets will be lucky to not get
swept
they are gonna be a four if not five
dollar favorite
to either the heat or the celtics take
your money and run
look you're gonna get a thousand bucks
off a 250 bet
you're good to go everybody else going
to tell you to cash out why this sports
book is offering you to cash out
for a very specific reason and that's
because they're trying to save
themselves 115 bucks
let it rise i'm with kelly here man i'm
with
i'm with you let it ride i mean i i have
a little bit of faith in the dead i have
more faith than you doing the denver
nuggets
because i'm a huge jamaal murray fan and
as a fan i just want to see that kid
shoot like score 50 points for the rest
of the playoffs
but you got to let it ride man like if
you if
you've come this far with that ticket
what's a few more games homie even
though i think the demonic is going to
win
you got to let it ride i hope
we're literally talking about 115 bucks
here
literally 115 bucks i mean anything
can happen anything can happen in this
laker team
don't pull out this championship so mike
my guy
look at me cash out it's only 115
don't listen to what kelly's saying just
cash out take your money go parlay it
flip it double it you know what i'm
talking about the
diameter locks yeah dude yeah this is
the jg wentworth it's my money and i
want it now go get the 910 good math
there greg
that backs up my point even further i'd
never say ever ever say cash out
in this case why the hell not it's my
money i want it now
go put it on a nerfy now you're 1800 by
the time the finals start and then you
reinvest
one week ago should anyone listen to
somebody
one week ago mikey locks would have let
it ride
and now he looks so dumb so
do not be mikey locks from a week ago
i'm a hollow shell yeah i'm a sucked
back loser
cannot hurt me any further the
guaranteed 900 bucks
you made a great billy stop laughing
good job yeah
i cannot stop laughing at you i will
never be able to take you seriously ever
again for the rest of my life great
it's kind of why it's kind of fun i kind
of like it too
oh yeah i'm rocking i'm rocking with the
stash mike you definitely pull it off
bro
like no you should do a half a beard if
it looks like no shave half your beard
who me
kind of looks good greg greg what are
the comments saying
the comments the people are in the
comments and
and they're spinning they're spitting
that true fire in the comments my guy
aaron jones oh aaron joseph zero he said
cash out
jimmy buckets won't be stopped i agree
with that
my my guy go white sox says
let it ride hmm i don't know if i agree
with that i'mma give aaron joseph a
hoodie
go white sox i don't agree with that
take brother
i miss you i miss those guys and gals
who's in there greg what are the
comments like
not only did you guys make me do this
you took the comments from me so i can't
even
check out and just hang out with like
geek the deke uh who else is in there
hype face
all the homies in there in here for sure
d
geek zeke's in here uh joe yan's in here
jake the snake is in here max levingston
is in the building uh they they're all
in here
i miss the homies a little behind the
scenes a little inside info
uh our producers actually didn't want
mikey vlogs to be reading comments
because they were worried about his you
know ability to read so
greg i'm happy you're that's fair
running the show i'm actually not gonna
argue
you need more emojis just keep hammering
the emojis
[Laughter]
all right best of luck to you at no
limit b824
whatever you decide we got to take a
look at the current series odds
we have lakers nuggets all right
obviously lakers
massive favorites kelly honestly
is there any value to the nuggets here
25 to 1.
i'm super shocked that the the lakers
minus 10 000 isn't
mikey locks lock of the century i
figured he'd be touting that up and down
on the show
i don't tout anything i've never touted
anything in my life i'm out here
grinding
everything true i'm grinding
i'm losing everything yo lots you can't
be out here
lying anymore bro and on our first or
second show you're like i'm on the box
i'm on the lakers and the clippers
you've been on okay okay easy favorites
bro okay
let's unpack i never took the bucks by
anyone the lakers and the clippers minus
ten thousand kelly
i kind of like the nuggets 25 to one
they've done it before how you like the
nuggets i i need all the nuggets at 25
to one nine
good value how do you like it plus 2500
got it give me a win tonight game three
on tnt
yo how have you become how have you
become the guy that bets on
everything bro like that's why you're
always broke you don't pick your spots
you're just like you spin the wheel like
i'll take that one that one that one
that one that one that one
uh i agree with that is that not a good
way to bet i thought that was how you're
supposed to do you gotta watch
you're gonna win i can't can we just get
through this show
i am not going to make it i cannot look
it down at the monitor for one more
second at mikey it is
what's up america big five
let's talk eastern conference miami is
only a slight favor
despite being up again here is anyone
taking
boston cabbie are you taking boston
no you know i'm not taking boston you
know emotionally i have a problem
with all things boston celtics listen
they had to have a
fight in the locker room after game two
in order to motivate themselves to have
a
great game three like marcus smart and
jaylen brown
had to eat uh um exchange heated words
in order to get them to what they had
listen they had a great game three jalen
sorry jason tatum almost had a triple
double they had four guys and
um they had four guys and who score over
20 points
and uh jay crowder and goran dragons
only went four for 20 in game three
that's not going to happen again
the dragon has been the best player in
the bubble
we're talking about dragon come on yo
golden dragon is legit
his name he is dibs on being marcus
smart of the group chat i'm just gonna
go off on all y'all
and dave crowder has been on a mission
from downtown
that's not gonna happen again in game
like game four in the rest of the series
it's going to be the miami heat that are
gonna
meet whomever in the western conference
final that's how i see it
that's how i believe it you can book it
cabbie's absolutely right
listen the heat are gonna advance
they're gonna represent the east
in the finals against the lakers
unfortunately
listen my nuggets tickets done i didn't
hedge and and i probably should have
that being said
the nuggets might surprise you guys over
the next couple of games oh
they're not going to surprise anybody
everybody should know they're here
they're the hottest team in the bubble
they've covered an insurmountable amount
of games at this point in time and
they're going to continue to do so like
cabbie said
the last game for the celtics game three
was kind of fluky it took a big blow up
in the locker room and it took
their star players all coming together
at the same time
jimmy buckets and his crew will get it
done game four i see this one
ending here shortly greg you're gonna be
a blow up in this locker room
and someone's gonna throw big face
coffee all over your shirt
i am it's booty time greg it's booty
time
vern i'm in the comments and i'm seeing
a lot
of people on miami's bandwag on the
miami bandwagon
uh no i can't give you a jerk d d you
you probably have five of them already
but it does
my guy jeffrey mccann my guy jeffrey
mccann says butler's running it i'm
gonna give you a hoodie
mjm one one two two jimmy buckets is
going to the finals
he said that so he's gonna get a hoodie
okay my guy
bay legend he's from the base so i gotta
hook him up i gotta hook him up bay
legend
miami is looking fire right now i would
not bet against them
kelly they're rocking with you cabbie
they're rocking with you
i see i don't know who i don't know
who's going to win i like boston maybe
miami get it but
in the comments that rocco with miami
have spoken g-money
i like that i like boston me and
governor
yeah mikey and i are back yeah i see you
yeah there it is
everyone except us gets rich on these
same game
parlays they you see them over and over
again
we have got to hit one not just to get
mikey
a proper haircut but also just for group
morale
so kelly did you write that that's
important no did you write that before
or was that just here
all right kelly where are you i'm proud
of you we're gonna pitch you
you have to take the two worst takes
here from the group
and then we will let the audience decide
which to vote off the island so we don't
mess up the parlay
all right a little same game parlay
survivor i will start
i'm taking our time okay why not us wait
we have to hit one of these we're dude
straight up i've got lebron over 26 and
a half points
you know he's going to get real close
there
80d he's at two monster games i think he
comes back down to earth a little bit
lebron picks up the slack so i'm taking
the over 26 and a half
so okay vern i i i i like that i like
that
i'm not gonna disagree with that but i
got another one i got another one for
the parley
my leg of the parlay is it's it's
playoff rondo time he has to show up
today
so i'm going with rondo going over
seven and a half points in today's game
i could see him hitting about three
threes you know rondo he got that shot
cabbie he didn't have it back in the day
but he got it now
so i'm rocking with my guy uh playoff
rondo
is it my turn to give some analysis okay
here we go when you talk about
mike vernon okay you talk about someone
who might be losing his hair a little
bit
who has played over 25 minutes upwards
of 30 minutes in the last couple games
who's averaged
well over five and a half points at the
end of the day you look at vern
over five and a half points for the game
we're already taking him to make a
bucket in the first quarter
so we like burns alex caruso
i i am so athletic so i see the
comparison i get it
you know thank you yep there's the hair
thank you person
fern has an underrated 40-inch vert like
that's right
i'm gonna show some love to the denver
nuggets and the big man
nicola jokic who is a generational
talent talent
he is an elite passer perhaps the best
passing big man
in the history of the association now
his team
he's put his team on his shoulders jamal
murray is right there with him
but i see he's going to get over six and
a half assists because
frank vogel is throwing out dwight
howard throwing out javale mcgee
and anthony davis so trying to limit the
amount of touches
or the amount of scoring that jokic does
so jokic because he's got such a high iq
he's gonna ditch the ball six and a half
assists we're going over
that's the parlay
all right here's all of ours kelly i
forgot i was waiting for your pick
no you have to tell us which of these
are the worst takes
kelly pick the two worse then the
audience will vote one out
uh so kelly what do you have
listen vern i love to bet against you
whenever i get a chance
i'm not betting against lebron and a man
on a mission
game two he scored this in the first
half and it was all she wrote
i'm not i'm not disagreeing with you
there as far as greg goes ron
rondo has been playoff rondo he's looked
really great i don't want to step in
front of the hot hand that
the lakers need that third guy to step
up sorry mikey
his name is not caruso all of a sudden
my dudes get
kind of hyped no no doubt he's he's a
great fifth guy out there off the bench
five and a half points five and a half
minutes two threes
it looks too easy it ain't gonna happen
cabbie
i want to agree with you here i do like
the nuggets tonight
jokage scares me i think we're going to
see
one or two joke itches tonight one we
see what we saw in game one where he
fouls out basically early and sees the
bench
for a significant part of the game or
two he's gonna take over
and have to hit some monster shots
meaning not passing the ball
so it's a toss-up between the joker and
uh vern 2.0
thank you you we're back we're back
after that last comment oh hi
all right tell us in the comments whose
bet is messing up our game three par
light
is it the jokic assist or is it caruso
points
greg we're hammering crusade while you
guys
while you guys do that mikey
we have to discuss how long you need to
keep the half mustache
we need to we need to make some clear
ground rules here
so mike i never agreed to a half
mustache in the first place
and you're gonna come out here in front
of everyone again and try to make up
some bs about hard to keep the half
muscles
i did that for the vibes to start the
show the mustache is coming off
right after the show is over don't be
the guy who changes the terms of the bet
after the bets made that's very very
unbecoming on you you don't even need
you to make another bet
like with the fate of your hair don't
don't make a bet we gotta get to
like clearly he's gonna i paid my best
he's gonna i have him
i look like an absolute idiot in front
of everyone
i will get the tattoo and there's a lot
going on right now okay tattoo's gonna
happen hey forget the tattoo burn put
the tattoo aside
bird mikey just said that he always pays
his bets what kind of crypto did he use
to pay off his most recent debt to you
so after a long period of time i paid
you
of mikey owen hold on he stumbled into
his
coin base account he was like oh i have
250 bucks i had
coincidentally exactly what i owe you in
some not normal coin ethereum which is
fine
and that's a good point can i pay you in
this this is how i want to pay you
so sure yeah fine then the payment comes
through i'm traveling
and there's some kind of crypto crash on
monday and so i've already lost
50 bucks of what you already
that's a good coin and that's on you for
not pulling out no that's on you don't
try and point fingers don't sit here and
point fingers at me
after i made you that six hundred
dollars did i not make you that six
hundred dollars
we had it betting for you together i
owed you the money took me a little bit
to buy back
because you lost all of it and then
started betting with my money
in the first place well i had to get it
back i was that's how i was gonna get it
back
right now by betting with my money it
doesn't make it easy
then i got then i found the coin base
and we we're good we're good i always
pay my bets
don't be a buzzer because you can't
dinmo 250 you had to find some random
coin
you're right though look we're fine
we're fine it's in my account
kelly says i'm gonna let it ride and
make money
and i trust kelly so thank you all right
greg what are the people saying who's
getting kicked out of the parliament
i am seeing a lot of cabbies getting
kicked out the party a lot of jokers
getting kicked yo get just one of the
best passers in the history of
basketball
what do you mean guys uh byu
bingles red says greg do you have my
back
look at me yes i have you're back and
you're getting a hoodie just for that
in matt tovski and matt tolsky he said
greg
i know your eyes are giving me i know
you're giving me those eyes in the
comments i can see it brother i see you
yes you're also getting the hoodie um
but yeah cabbie i'm sorry man they're
not rocking with you
uh they're rocking with my guy caruso
going over five and a half points
i got i got to be super straight with
you guys if i already got kicked out of
this group chat
to end the show after everything that
happened i would have never straight up
never recovered from it so
i really appreciate it i needed that
trying right now
i felt the vibes mike i got you thank
you splitbot
you guys decided let's take a look at
the official parlay here
we've got lebron over points we've got
caruso over points and rondo over point
we're simple people here we're just
taking some
over prop points cabbie you've been
booted from the chat so
you know apologies
yeah i think it looks good you're right
greg we might keep it i told you
let it let it ride remember let it ride
mikey god i needed that you're a
champion
for just playing along and you're also
maybe a
horrible bet but you do pick your no i'm
definitely you should just buzz your
whole hedge
on the show i mean i'm down
no no no okay absolutely not just both
of us are hammering used to be so much
fun
most of us are hammering alex cruzo in
game three mikey you are no longer
fun cabbie cannot defend himself he's
still hurting inside from his raptor's
loss
and he also messed up the parlay
if you want a hoodie today we will dm
you and now
it is time to leave the chat mikey i
hope you saw the mustache next week but
i know you won't
i'm dead inside let it ride
let it ride we're leaving the chat
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you